salut c'est hugo aujourd'hui c'est au
tour de fabien roussel le candidat du
parti communiste français de se prêter à
l'exercice de mon interview face cachée
quand il a d'abord été journaliste avant
de s'engager en politique au parti
communiste français et devenir député du
nord en 2017 c'est la première fois
qu'il se présente à l'élection
présidentielle et c'est aussi la
première fois depuis 2007 que le parti
communiste français présente un candidat
en effet en 2012 et en 2017 le parti
avait soutenu jean luc mélenchon ce qui
n'est pas le cas ce stade dans
l'interview face cachée vous l'avez vu
avec les autres candidats fabien roussel
fait face à un écran géant sur lequel
défilent idées et mogi il ya plusieurs
reprises pendant l'interview il va
appuyer sur un buzzer pour que la route
s'arrête sur un emoji la face cachée de
chacun des émaux gives a révélé
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond concernant son programme et
concernant sa vision de la france alors
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à cette chaîne youtube pour nous
soutenir et ne pas louper les interviews
suivantes ainsi que les présentations
des programmes des candidats et les
autres vidéos qu'on fait plus
généralement je vous laisse avec la
vidéo bonjour fabien roussel bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon
invitation est ce que les règles sont
claires est-ce que c'est clair je suis
moi-même voir démarrer du coup on va
voir démarrer sans plus tarder je vous
invite appuyée sur le buzzer
ça va c'est en fait c'est toujours un
délai et ça s'arrête sur un premier et
mogi c1 une affiche une image qui va
apparaître on va la découvrir ensemble
c'est en l'occurrence vous le voyez très
bien d'autres affiches de campagne
fabien roussel le défi des jours heureux
c'est un slogan ce1 que vous allez
porter ici déjà qu'est ce que ça veut
dire le défi des jours heureux pour ça
c'est là la première affiche la première
fois que l'on décide au mois de mais
décide de mettre le défi des jours
heureux les jours heureux parce que on
s'est dit quand même y en a marre de
subir à chaque fois des réformes
difficiles
que l'on demande aux français et on a
besoin de réformes heureuse voilà et
dans cette campagne on entend déjà ce
qu'ils disent vous travaillerez plus
c'est vous qui paierez attention il ya
la dette nous on dit il ya suffisamment
de richesses pour mettre en place des
réformes heureuse donc c'est le droit au
bonheur c'est une référence au conseil
national de la résistance et le
programme des jours heureux alors il a
conçu en 1944
c'est aussi ça je sais qu'en utilisant
ce slogan en choisissant ça ça va parler
aux anciens à ceux qui connaissent un
peu l'histoire le conseil national de la
résistance a écrit le programme des
jours heureux ils l'ont écrit à
plusieurs mains il y avait des
gaullistes il y avait des communistes y
avait tout ceux qui se sont engagés dans
la résistance en même temps qui tenait
la mitraillette il écrivait la
reconstruction de la france et c'est ce
programme-là qui a fait les les trente
glorieuses et donc on a pris ça mais je
sais aussi pour tous les jeunes pour qui
ça veut rien dire parce qu'ils n'ont pas
cette référence au cnr en fait avec
cette pandémie j'en entends qui me
disent mais on a besoin de respirer on a
besoin de croire au bonheur on en a
envie donc c'était aussi ça et comme
pour tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle on va rentrer dans le
détail de votre programme mais vous êtes
à la tête du parti communiste français
ça veut dire quoi être communiste
aujourd'hui en france m le parti
communiste français il a ses racines ici
et il a une histoire dans notre pays qui
est long qui date d'un siècle il est
notre notre idéal est un idéal de
justice de partage et de solidarité
ce que l'on met ce que je mets derrière
parti communiste français s'est autant
les congés payés les grandes conquêtes
sociales la reconstruction de la france
la résistance mais c'est aussi les
luttes contre la décolonisation contre
l'apartheid pour l'indépendance de
l'algérie c'est tout ça à la fois c'est
un parti pour la paix internationaliste
mais aussi toujours aux côtés
du monde du travail du monde ouvrier et
pour bien comprendre c'est un courant de
pensée évidemment politique qui vient
notamment s'opposer au capitalisme en eu
l'occasion de recevoir un certain nombre
de candidats à l'élection présidentielle
à gauche ou à l'extrême gauche notamment
nathalie artaud ou encore philippe
poutou qui eux mêmes se disent
communiste nathalie arthaud se dit
communiste révolutionnaire est ce que
vous souhaitez sortir complètement du
capitalisme a je pense que ce système
économique est à bout de souffle il
fonde sa compagnie là je vais pour le
capitalisme en france celui notamment
qui a poussé à la à l'industrialisation
à la fin du 19e au début du xxème a
certainement permis de des progrès dans
le pays mais en même temps il a provoqué
beaucoup d'exploitations et de
souffrance pour impôts pour les français
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle quand on
voit qu'il faut sauver le climat sauver
la planète eh bien nous disons qu'il est
urgent de sortir de ce système dont la
seule logique c'est la course au profit
c'est l'argent à tout prix bien nous
nous disons qu'il faut mettre l'être
humain et la planète au coeur de toutes
les logiques politiques et d'oise par
consisté en termes de grandes mesures en
gestion va pas rentrer dans les détails
a nommé ça repose sur deux principes de
c'est bien sûr mieux répartir les
richesses et ça c'est ce que nous sommes
nombreux à dire à gauche mieux répartir
les richesses c'est à dire c'est pas
normal qu'on distribue des dividendes
quant à nous on nous demande de faire de
nous serrer la ceinture donc ça c'est la
répartition des richesses c'est lisf il
faut rétablir c'est tout simple mais
nous nous disons autre chose c'est que
les richesses nous voulons les produire
autrement et ça c'est fondamental parce
que justement au nom d urgence sociale
au nom d urgence climatique nous ne
pouvons plus produire de la même manière
il faut respecter le vivant il faut
respecter l'être humain il faut
respecter la biodiversité
il faut respecter les ressources
naturelles donc nous voulons produire
autrement et pour ça on veut se
réapproprier nos moyens de production
vont donner des pouvoirs de nouveaux
pouvoirs aux salariés dans les
entreprises non l'occasion je pense en
reparler pendant 700 et rejoue on va
passer du coup à la question vente pour
ça je à deux heures ça va ralentir
progressivement et ça va s'arrêter le
mot cette fois ci sur le monde ou une
carte c'est logique car précisément
derrière ça on va découvrir donc une
carte vous le voyez ici c'est une carte
issue en l'occurrence de la fp l' agence
france-presse
on va simplifier un peu ce qu'on voit
sur cette carte pour ceux qui nous
regardent et qui sait de comprendre avec
tout ce qu'on voit ici c'est l'âge des
réacteurs nucléaires en france et une
carte réalisée par la lfp en 2021 pour
qu'est-ce que déjà vous constatez de
votre côté en regardant ça d'abord que
nous avons un parc de centrales
nucléaires important sur notre pays et
que c'est plutôt une chance parce que
c'est grâce à ça que nous avons 75 % de
notre production d'électricité qui est
décarbonée qui est pilotable ça veut
dire que quand on en a besoin on appuie
sur un bouton et deux ans après on à
l'électricité qui permet de répondre aux
besoins quand on branche les voitures
tous ensemble le soir quand un grand
coup de froid on ne dépend pas ni de
l'éolien ni du solaire ni d'autres pays
en cas de guerre c'est important et donc
c'est pour moi important après je vois
la joie à travers cette carte qui lie à
des réacteurs vieux complique 41 ans est
donc la deuxième chose alors qu'à
l'origine il était construit en général
tout à fait entre 30 à 40 ans et
l'incertain ce qui me fait d'ailleurs
qu'il est urgent important d'investir
dans la modernisation de ce parc dans
l'installation de nouveaux réacteurs
pour justement pouvoir et sécurisé et
sécurisée avec de nouvelles centrales
neuves moderne mais aussi pouvoir sortir
des énergies fossiles
si on veut se si on veut ne plus
utiliser le charbon le pétrole et même
le gaz à terme il va falloir produire
plus d'électricité
même si on fait de la sobriété
énergétique
il va falloir plus il va falloir
produire plus pour remplacer toutes ses
énergies et c'est une là une différence
majeure pour bien comprendre ça ira tout
seul parfois d'autres à gauche par
exemple il ya notamment yannick jadot
donc le candidat du parti europe
écologie r qui explique notamment il est
l'occasion de venir là aussi sur cette
chaîne qui explique un réacteur qui
vieillit peut potentiellement explose et
que ça peut être une région entière qui
peut se retrouver des zestes et l'enjeu
de la sécurité c'est un argument qui est
avancé par beaucoup à gauche pour sortir
du nucléaire qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cet angle là mais je dis que c'est un
vrai enjeu ils ont raison c'est hyper
important est que justement il faut
avoir confiance dans nos ingénieurs dans
nos techniciens dans nos compétences
françaises en matière nucléaire
d'ailleurs faute d'avoir investi ces
dernières années on voit comment on a eu
du mal à faire flamanville et que ça
nous coûte à bras parce qu'on n'a pas
assez investi dans ses compétences
malgré tout dans celles qui existent et
que j'ai eu l'occasion d'exister moi je
fais confiance à ceux qui sont là bas il
faut investir dans la sûreté dans la
sécurité et donc dans la formation et on
ne doit pas jouer avec ça il n'y a
jamais eu d'incident majeur dans notre
pays
heureusement et donc de ne doit y avoir
aucun risque de prix en matière de
sécurité et donc ce sont des
investissements à faire humain
matériel pour justement garantir une
stricte sécurité un autre argument
avancé par ceux qui sont favorables la
sortie progressive du nucléaire et sont
nombreux à gauche la question des
déchets radioactifs dont on ne sait pas
dans certains cas se débarrasser comment
est ce qu'on fait pour gérer ses déchets
nucléaires est ce que c'est vraiment
viable de se retrouver dans une telle
situation avec des déchets qui de fait
s'accumulent au fil des années dans
toutes les productions
d'énergie d'électricité on à cette
question des déchets à traiter voilà
même dans la presse
conrad black sabbath et pour des
centaines d'années mais de toute façon
on a cette question à traiter on l'aura
avec les batteries de la même manière
avec les métaux rares de la même manière
alors
moi je d'abord il ya des dd je les
déchets des centrales d'aujourd'hui
qu'il faut sécuriser protéger et ne pas
les délégués dans des pays étrangers ce
qui serait inadmissible on doit en
assumer la responsabilité
mais surtout ce que je demande est ce
que je propose
d'investir dans la recherche tout de
suite maintenant pour faire en sorte que
demain et c'est possible les chercheurs
moody's nous puissions avoir des
centrales des réacteurs nucléaires qui
utilisent les déchets radioactifs c'est
à dire qu'ils recyclent et qui fait que
l'on n'a plus à avoir a à
cacher à mettre de côté ses déchets on
va les jours notamment sur sa faim il
faut utiliser il faut investir dans la
recherche il ne faut pas en avoir peur
il faut la maîtriser
l'énergie nucléaire verra peut-être
petites questions là dessus que c'est un
enjeu majeur la question de l'énergie
seront bien sûr donc là on a une carte
on le disait du parc nucléaire français
aujourd'hui pour résumer votre
positionnement est aussi même pour
comprendre notamment par rapport à
emmanuel macron et les annonces comme
une lettre récemment dans la situation
actuelle qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
construit des nouveaux réacteurs jeu
mais vous êtes président est-ce qu'on
maintient ce actuellement place qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec les centrales
nucléaires qui existe aujourd'hui
d'abord on sécurise et combien ça coûte
aussi conclure ils ont investi dans les
anciennes on protège et donc il y à des
travaux à faire et il faut les faire
deuxièmement il faut créer de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires et donc c'est la
production en série de six à huit
réacteurs parce que si on en fait ces
mini réacteur ensemble et en même temps
nous pourrons les faire rapidement il en
faut six à huit tout de suite je propose
dans le même temps d'investir aussi dans
les énergies renouvelables je suis pas
un anti éoliens anti solaire au
contraire nous allons aussi en avoir
besoin du solaire de l'éolien et de la
géothermie mais aussi sur tous nos
barrages hydroélectriques c'est eux 80%
des énergies renouvelables et il faut
les protéger dans un service public
c'est ça qui est important en attendant
votre position sur le site nucléaire et
qui vaut le coup pour comprendre le
positionnement par rapport à d'autres
candidats notamment notamment à gauche
on va c'est justement la question
suivante est pour ca du conte relance là
où normalement voilà je vous laisse la
pluie vous souhaitez et la roue va
ralentir sur un démo j
c'est en l'occurrence un téléphone
quelque chose va s'afficher derrière on
va le découvrir ensemble alors c'est un
même que vous avez peut-être vu ou
peut-être pas d'ailleurs qui illustre
alors n'arrive pas forcément à le dire
beaucoup donc je vais le décrire les
candidats de gauche exactement à corte
en hésitations face au candidat de
gauche parce que de fait il y en a
beaucoup c'est un même sur lequel est
tombé notamment jean luc mélenchon
lorsque j'ai interviewé il ya quelques
jours alors l'idée là c'est pas de
reparler d'une union de la gauche ou de
tout ça parce qu'on a quelques jours
d'une élection mais c'est davantage de
comprendre justement les différences
entre chacun des candidats pour que ceux
qui seraient intéressés par programme
puisse comprendre concrètement les
distinctions qu'est ce qui vous
différencie selon vous des autres
candidatures à gauche qui peuvent
exister aujourd'hui bon d'abord je
souhaite incarner une gauche populaire
laïque républicaine féministe écologiste
jeu mais l'enceinte de ces noeuds bah
oui mais on a des différences là dessus
j'ai fait je viens d'expliquer en quoi
sur la question énergétique j'étais le
seul à marquer cette différence et je
l'assumé je suis aussi pour prendre des
sujets par exemple je le dis dès le
début de ma campagne la question de la
tranquillité publique jeu l'assument et
je souhaite qu'on puisse garantir la
tranquillité de tous et donc je le dis
il faut investir investir dans la
justice lors donner les moyens de juger
et de juger vite il faut donner des
moyens aussi à nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et moi je souhaite avoir des
gardiens de la paix au service du peuple
au service d'un gouvernement quand y
mènent des politiques antisociales et je
souhaite investir dans des services
publics pour garantir la sécurité de
tous dans tous les quartiers donc cette
question la tranquillité publique moi
j'en ai fait comme un sujet de
différenciation en disant j'y tiens et
je veux la défendre et la garantir pour
tous là dessus je me suis fait un peu
tapé d'ailleurs mais non ça fait partie
des sujets et puis je défendrai publique
laïque laïque la laïcité en france c'est
le droit de croire et de ne pas croire
et de le garantir pour tous c'est aussi
un état une république qui ne
subventionne et ne reconnaît aucun culte
et ça j'y tiens comme à la prunelle de
mes yeux quand j'interviens jean luc
mélenchon il ya quelques jours il disait
lui même qui ne comprenaient pas
forcément pourquoi est ce que le parti
communiste français avait fait peu
cavalier seul pour cette élection il
disait que justement il voyait beaucoup
de points communs avec sa candidature
sur le fond sur le programme quelle
distinction quelle différence est ce que
vous faites justement avec jean luc
mélenchon plus clair je comprends qu'ils
comprennent pas à les deux derniers
après ses précédentes élections nous
étions ensemble il aura bien et fait
aimer quand qu'on recommence une
troisième fois mais d'abord la dernière
fois on était ensemble ça lui a pas
permis de gagner et je remarque
aujourd'hui il a beaucoup moins de voix
que ce qu'il avait en 2010 est donc il a
perdu une part de son électorat je suis
pour rien c'est une réalité est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il est dans les
sondages à 10 11% moi je pige regrets en
tête à gauche et moi je progresse sans
lui prendre des lecteurs ce que je
remarque c'est des gens qui me le disent
les gens me disent enfin avec vous
monsieur roussel on retrouve une vraie
voix à gauche nous ne voterons plus pour
d'autres candidats nous ne voterons pas
pour jean luc mélenchon je crois qu'en
plus jean duc il a aussi déçu une partie
de des français quand il a dit la
république c'est moi par son tempérament
par ses passes et ses déclarations et
que une présidentielle un président de
la république ça doit aussi sa carnet et
donc on doit être en capacité de
rassembler tous les français je suis un
pacificateur je veux moi tendre la main
à tout le monde et être le président de
tous les français demain sans sectarisme
sans outrance et sans excès et c'est
aussi ça peut-être une des différences
que je souhaite pouvoir incarner mais ce
que je dis aussi c'est que ni lui ni moi
ne gagneront tout seul et que donc nous
devrons au second tour pouvoir nous unir
et qui sait c'est peut-être moi qui
arriverait pas et du coup
c'est pour ça que je suis sans animosité
sans haine sans adversité je souhaite
que l'on puisse travailler ensemble
demain dans un gouvernement que bien sûr
si je suis élu président de la
république je construirai avec lui mais
aussi avec toutes les autres forces de
gauche moi je n'ai pas j'ai pas de
hierges ehpad invectives mais un premier
tour ça sert aussi pour les français de
dire ce qu'ils veulent est ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas et on voit bien que moi par
ma candidature ce que j'incarne comme je
suis comment je parle douche bien chaude
à ch'ti je m'attaque à l'évasion fiscale
serait de là dessus eh ben je vois que
j'arrive à convaincre des gens des
abstentionnistes même des gens qui
votent à l'extrême droite même des gens
qui votaient macron qui me disent ah bah
lui lui me plaît tu lui parles pas comme
les autres lui et est donc ils vont
voter pour moi donc je pense que au
contraire ça peut ça peut redonner des
belles couleurs des belles couleurs à
une belle gauche on a une belle droite
au pouvoir ben moi j'aimerais bien
quelle belle gauche demain on verra du
coup comment se passe à la suite de
cette campagne présidentielle je relance
cette roue je vous laisse l'arrêté
cette cuve à ralentir sur autre chose un
croc de m un exercice à chaque fois
c'est à ces partis du lycée ça
exactement une minute je vais vous poser
un maximum de questions il faut réglable
oui non par oui ou par non il conçoit
ses chaussées jeudi je me suis dit oui
non mais qu'il faut donner moi quelques
secondes je vous laisse faire le mieux
possible sachant que la force d'avoir
des questions qu'ils sont d'accord a
priori possible de répondre en par un
oui ou pour un non est-ce que vous êtes
prêts
doit-on pouvoir prendre l'avion pour
faire un paris marseille oui faut-il
réduire le temps de travail en france
oui faut-il quitté l'otan oui la police
at-elle trop de pouvoir
faut-il légaliser le cannabis
non je suis plus pour la dépénalisation
allez vous remettre en place l'impôt sur
la fortune oui oui oui aussi augmenter
le smic à 1500 milles 900 euros brut il
faut du brut irez vous soutenir l'équipe
de france à la coupe du monde au qatar
si vous êtes élu
rio non c'est une vraie question est oui
j'y serai faut-il abc le droit de vote à
16 ans
non parce que c'est un risque ça veut
dire la majorité à 16 ans et ça veut
dire aussi en matière pénale qui on
juger comme des adultes doit-on
supprimer la sélection à l'entrée des
universités oui l'allemagne est-elle la
meilleure alliée de la france c'est une
alliée dernière question faut-il rendre
gratuit le permis de conduire pour les
moins de 25 ans oui
on est on a eu tout juste eu le temps de
rona un fait qu'on me de question on a
fait une bonne dizaine - dizaines et
vous soutenir l'équipe de france à la
coupe du monde au qatar si vous êtes élu
vous répondre je sais que c'est
compliqué en fait penser que c'est
compliqué parce que je ne l'envisagé un
boycott diplomatique
bah oui et en même temps il ya l'équipe
de france
quelle connerie que la fifa ait décidé
d'attribuer la coupe du monde au qatar
c'est une ou leur appel des milliers de
scandales et ont été de même pour le
climat pour l'être humain ce pur c'est
un scandale c'est un scandale sans nom
sans nom puisque des laissez-passer
soutenait alors oui eh bien peut-être
qu'il faudrait envoyer
premier ministre ou un ministre ou
comment faire ou alors on y va pas ou
alors c'est enfin certains envisagent un
boycott diplomatique comme je le fais
moi raja certains pays les états unis ne
touchent certains de deux députés
sénateurs communistes disent qu'il faut
boycotter qui va pas du tout y aller
faut même pas envoyé l'équipe
c'est une vraie question bon moi je suis
je suis plutôt du côté de ceux qui
disent que le sport c'est un vecteur de
fraternité d'émancipation et donc il
faut au contraire pouvoir y aller pour
faire valoir ses valeurs et au qatar ça
a du sens on va passer à la question
suivante je relance la rouge vous laisse
là l'été
c'est con qui s'arrêtait sur un autre et
mogi cadeau c'est un cadeau mais c'est
un cadeau laissé par un autre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle un candidat
vous a posé une question on va l'écouter
je vous laisse y répondre juste après
fabien roussel y est nous on est
d'accord sur le bon vin mais ton vin
c'est aussi du vin bio et du vin nature
pour respecter la terre pour qu'ils
aient plus de paysans qu'ils soient
payés décemment et qu'on protège notre
santé yannick jadot candidat des
écologistes est-ce que vous lui répondez
moi je réponds pour à cette question en
disant bien sûr et bien sûr et et
d'ailleurs quand je dis un bon vin ou
une bonne viande puisque c'est
d'expression que des sorties et qu'on
m'a reproché mais c'est d'ailleurs une
bonne viande produite en france un bon
vin issu de nos terroirs et respectant
des normes phytosanitaires
importante et les agriculteurs les
paysans
trouve cherchent par tous les bouts de
produire de la manière la plus saine
possible et on doit les accompagner pour
ça ça veut dire quoi concrètement en
termes de mesures est ce que on interdit
des pesticides est ce que on sort de
certains éléments qu'est-ce qu'on fait
concrètement oui et on soutient celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui cherchent à
mettre en place des jeux je sais pas si
on peut se mettre d'accord sur ce terme
aider des pesticides bio c'est à dire
utilisant des produits naturels pour
aller attaquer des d'autres des
mauvaises herbes des animaux etc on peut
le faire de manière naturelle et j'ai
rencontré une start up en bretagne qui
travaille là dessus et cette jeune femme
ingénieur qui est en train d'en mettre
au point pour de protéger les vignes et
la pomme pour faire valoir son brevet
écoutez ça pour faire valoir son brevet
il faut sept ans à la commission
européenne pour valider son brevet et ça
lui coûte entre 100 à 150 mille euros on
n'aide pas à développer de lever les
récents france on est pas les chefs
d'entreprise les six jeunes startups
starter à à mettre en place et c'est sur
les cv sur les pesticides c'est un débat
important et j'ai compris auprès de
certains agriculteurs qui estime qu' ils
en ont besoin pour leur production etc
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à cette
inquiétude qu ils peuvent savoir alors
qu'ils sont il faut le dire de nos
agriculteurs déjà dans une très grande
discuter mais je leur dis qu'on va
avancer ensemble et les agriculteurs ils
me disent mais on nous traite
d'empoisonner heures mais nous les
produits qu'on utilise sont des produits
que l'on nous enseigne à l'école à
utiliser c'est ceux qui sont agréés par
l'état donc site un produit si un
produit est nocif provoque des cancers
il doit être interdit moi j'ai une femme
agricultrice de chez moi de ma
circonscription
qui fait du lait qui a des vaches 10 mai
et qui a des produits fermiers dit mais
moi j'en foisonnent pas mes enfants je
enfin je sais c'est incroyable donc
permettons à nos paysans de produire st
et puis surtout faisons le en respectant
la terre et les animaux et en tenant
compte du climat et donc en produisant
locale parce que quand on importe des
agneaux de nouvelle zélande du boeuf
d'argentine ou du poulet du brésil
bourrés d'antibiotiques la merde j'ai
décidé de libre échange avec l'ue mais
c'est à ça qu'il faut s'attaquer et
justement la viande et bien moi je veux
développer des élevages français en
plein air c'est à dire il faut du boeuf
élevé en plein air parce que les
prairies sa capture carbone et ça
respecte l'animal les fermes usines
j'aime pas moi j'aime que je défends les
fermes je défends les usines mais pas
les fermes usines on relance la roue et
je vous laisse l'arrêté
et ça s'arrête sur un emoji article un
article de presse va donc s'afficher à
l'écran plutôt un titre d'article il
sait csu du figaro fabien roussel pcf à
gauche je veux porter les questions de
sécurité une interview du figaro qui n'a
donc de septembre ça veut dire que selon
vous la gauche ne parle pas de sécurité
ouais j'ai tout et si mais pas assez mal
pas clair bob baum ap voilà et donc du
coup on manque de crédibilité et
et moi je pense qu'au contraire en
matière de sécurité et de tranquillité
publique je préfère ce mot là on a une
vision progressiste à porter c'est à
dire avoir une police des gardiens de la
paix des gendarmes au service de la paix
sociale et de la sécurité de tous à
neuilly on n'a pas de problème de
l'insécurité voilà mais dans les
villages dans des quartiers populaires
il y en a je connais beaucoup d'élus de
maire communiste et même de tous bords
qui se bat pour le maintien d'un
commissariat pour avoir plus de bleu
pour pour faire vivre la sécurité pour
tous et ça passe par quoi en terme de
mesures très concrètement alors je veux
une police de proximité proche des gens
c'est pour ça que je propose la création
d'une d'un service spécial une police de
proximité doté de 30 mille hommes et
femmes statutaire pas privé formés et
bien formés mais je souhaite aussi
mettre des moyens d'en quête d' enquêtes
avec des enquêteurs pour démanteler les
trafics avec des moyens pour aller
chercher l'argent là où il est dans les
banques avec des champions et
d'informatique pour aller débusquer le
blanchiment de l'argent les banques ont
une responsabilité énorme et ils savent
eux quand ils ont affaire à des
trafiquants et qui fait que l'argent
c'est des billets qui rentrent et
derrière c'est blanchi en passant par
des paradis fiscaux il faut il faut
attaquer les gros bonnets en les tapant
au porte monnaie et donc je veux
beaucoup plus de moyens d'en quête pour
attaquer les trafics et enfin des moyens
pour la justice qui doit pouvoir traiter
en temps en temps et en heure quand il y
à des dépôts de plainte c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on va s'attaquer aux
trafiquants il ya donc davantage aux
moyens que vous souhaitez mettre et pour
l'égalité femmes hommes et pour
l'égalité femmes au sein de la police
mais bien sûr parce que l'égalité
protéger des femmes des violences
sexuelles et sexistes ya un tas de
mesures à mettre en oeuvre mais savoir
des gens formés dans les commissariats
non même un homme à aller coûte au
recueil de plaintes est pas dire aux
femmes a quand même bon ben d'accord je
vais écouter votre mari et puis c'est
parole contre parole on peut plus faire
ça on doit protéger protéger les femmes
et croire leur parole est donc bien sûr
qu'il faut plus d'agents de police de
gendarmes pour ça c'est une question qui
a été qu'est revenue travailler à
quelques mois avec le hashtag double
peine qui illustrait la difficulté de
nombreuses femmes à pouvoir porter
plainte après avoir été victime par
exemple de viol sur la question de la
police on entend qu'elle est question
des enjeux de sécurité qui sont
importants les enjeux de moyens de la
police que vous venez d'évoquer avec des
investissements que vous souhaitez faire
il ya une autre dimension à cette
question de la police c'est le fait que
ye soit une crainte soit une haine de
certains envers la police aujourd'hui en
france c'est une question qui ressort
aussi dès qu'il ya des éléments de
violences policières qui peuvent être
soulevées par certains médias est-ce que
déjà vous utilisez vos employés vous ce
terme de violences policières pour
décrire certains actes qui fait je vais
très clair avec vous c'est une des
différences que j'ai avec jean luc
mélenchon et avec d'autres justement je
ne parle pas de violences policières et
je ne parle pas de police racistes jeudi
qu'il y à de la violence de la part de
policiers
condamnable innommable et d'ailleurs
quand elle quand elle est avéré qu on la
voit ils doivent être sanctionnés
durement il y à t policier raciste et
qui ont qui on compte qu'ils quitteront
qui ont des actes racistes quand des
propos racistes qui parlent mal et ça
doit être condamné et l'arrière archi a
une responsabilité énorme de faire vivre
les principes de la république mais j'en
connais des jeunes en fait moi j'en veux
dire en fait c'est parce que j'en
connais aussi des jeunes qui sont dans
la gendarmerie des policiers dans la
police et j'utilise cette expression
pour moi c'est comme je défends les
ouvriers c'est des ouvriers de la
sécurité ils en chient c'est dur pour
eux mais c'est parfois c'est dur parce
qu'ils sont mal employés mal utilisé et
même y vivent dans un climat où
effectivement il ya des racistes il y en
a il y en a des violents mais si la
hiérarchie elle condamne pas elle fait
pas respecter les règles de la
république eh ben ça dérive ça part en
live et donc moi je suis pour respecter
cette profession ne pas faire d'
amalgame restaurer des règles et faire
en sorte que la police soit au service
du peuple beau service de la paie donc
donner davantage de moyens à la police
pour qu'elle puisse faire faut remettre
sans être inquiété mais à l inverse
enfin parle inverse mais aussi sur la
question des violences policières ou des
violences faites par des policiers selon
comment vous le vous le dit la question
d'un meilleur contrôle d'un meilleur
suivi staff et il a raison c'est
stabilité de la hiérarchie on va passer
à la question suivante même si on aurait
pu parler pendant longtemps de ce sujet
qui est un sujet important je vous
laisse à pied sur le buzzer une nouvelle
fois
et clape
vous êtes tombés sur les mots jeux vidéo
une vidéo va donc s'afficher à l'écran
et on va pouvoir en parler ensemble
cette vidéo elle a été tournée il y a un
an en janvier 2021 par le journaliste
indépendant clément l'anneau aujourd'hui
rien n'a vraiment changé en tout cas
beaucoup d'étudiants ne s'en sortent
toujours pas chaque jour font ainsi la
queue pour récolter des aliments et
pouvoir se nourrir c'est détresse qui
est importante chez énormément de jeunes
étudiants mais pas que d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cette
urgence quelles sont les premières
mesures se veut être président que
souhaitait mettre en place pour répondre
à cette urgence je souhaite mettre en
place un revenu étudiants pour chaque
étudiant universelle à partir de 850
euros qui pourra monter à 1000 euros en
fonction s'il a un logement ou pas
pour que plus jamais plus jamais nos
étudiants soient obligés de faire la
queue de l'aide alimentaire mais surtout
pour qu'ils puissent étudier sans être
obligés de travailler je suis pour
rétablir la gratuité sur ce sujet là
c'est sûr c'est pour tous les étudiants
c'est pour certains étudiants c'est sous
quelles conditions alors moi je suis
venu faire 50 euros de manière
universelle parce que sinon c'est un
système comme les bourses en fonction
des revenus des parents aujourd'hui un
tiers de boursiers pour beaucoup déjà et
beaucoup c'est à 0 veut dire qu'ils ont
rien c'est juste qu'ils payent 0 les
frais d'inscription
donc moi je suis pour que ce soit
universel et compris le fils de bernard
arnault même l'épisode est le fils de
bernard arnault il aura son allocation
étudiante sauf que son père bernard
arnault hyper alliés seif est trois fois
plus cher alors ailleurs propres ce qui
va préférer si ça reste macron aussi
c'est moi mon avis va préférer macron et
qui fait payer les études de son gamin
plutôt que moi avec la location au tour
hier les ouvriers le désert on taxe
davantage les plus riches et on ne leur
donne pas 850 euros pour leur donner mon
cher l'eau l'école de la république
elle est universelle elle s'adresse à
tous sinon c'est l'école privée et on
paye en fonction de ses moyens l'école
de la république elle est ouverte à tous
et bernard arnault il est issu de
l'école de la république je crois qu'il
a grandi à roubaix et c'est l'été dans
l'école publique et donc on ne
sélectionne pas à l'entrée on fait pas
payer ceux qui sont plus riches c'est
l'éducation l'école de la réputation
déjà sur ses mains elle est universelle
et on doit enfin c'est une richesse de
faire en sorte que nos enfants quel que
soit leur classe sociale leur origine
leur différence leur handicap vivent
ensemble et les mêmes droits et c'est
pour ça que je voulais vous dire je suis
pour rétablir la gratuité d'entrée afin
d'aider frais d'inscription pour les
étudiants étrangers ça aussi c'est une
richesse pour nos enfants qu'ils vivent
ensemble et c'est une manière aussi
d'aider et de faire de la coopération
avec ces pays qui en ont besoin
une question aussi forcément de de
moyens qui se posent on comprend que
vous souhaitez en faire une priorité la
question de de l'éducation est-ce que
vous avez une idée du coût de comment
financer tout cela à partir de quoi
est-ce que c'est justement via la
taxation des plus riches que vous avez
évoquées ici comment est ce qu'on fait
en sorte de la renouveler le système
éducatif à tel qu'il fonctionne et
universitaire taxer les plus riches ça
suffira pas c'est clair lisf y rapporte
mon isf qui rapportera 10 12 milliards
d'euros or le budget de l'état je
veulent augmenter de 100 milliards
d'euros pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins création d'emplois dans les
services publics relocalisation
transition écologique donc il va falloir
aller plus loin pour remettre la main
sur nos richesses ce sont nos richesses
je vais être intransigeant dans la lutte
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale ça
c'est terminé c'est terminé une des
mesures que je mettrai en place je vais
pas tout développé que j'ai déposé
plusieurs textes de loi dans ce domaine
une démesure c'est le prélèvement à la
source des bénéfices des multinationales
au moins ça ça on peut le faire tout
seul enfin les multis le dire très
concrètement pour les relais le
pleinement à la source de nos impôts ça
y est c'est fait ça et et faisons on l'a
mis en place on sait le faire et bien
moi je demande que les bénéfices six des
multinationales soient taxés à la source
comme tout le monde avant que ces
bénéfices ne parte au luxembourg et
ensuite aux îles caïmans comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui ça rien que ça le régime
mère fille ça s'appelle c'est la
possibilité pour une entreprise de
décider de payer des impôts dans le pays
où elle a une filiale et où les impôts
sont moins chers c'est honteux c'est du
vol c'est du racket ça nous coûte 20
milliards d'euros 20 milliards d'euros
en moins dans le budget de l'état c'est
une source énorme et donc les
délinquants en col blanc c'est terminé
voilà moi je veux une finance éthique au
service du pays et donc on va y
travailler tous ensemble s'est retrouvé
la maîtrise de nos richesses donc ce
prélèvement à la source sur les
bénéfices n'ont évoqué ça devrait
rapporter combien seul alors ça comme ça
comment et pour rapporteur s'est tout de
suite 20 milliards d'euros la lutte
contre la fraude et les valois parents
parents oui c'est pas en mettre fin à ce
régime c'est 20 milliards d'euros la
lutte contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale en tout ces 80 milliards d'euros
par an qui manque au budget d'état vous
voyez je dis pas qu'on va les ré truc
les récupérer tout de suite mais pour
moi c'est un objectif ensuite bien sûr
quand je dis que nous voulons produire
différemment les rides et les richesses
et que nous voulons faire en sorte que
les emplois que nous allons créer en
france et nous voulons créer des emplois
créer de la richesse
5 millions d'emplois c'est mon objectif
en cinq ans 5 millions d'emplois ces 650
milliards d'euros de pipe en plus c'est
plus de gens qui cotisent non mais voilà
france et la turquie a cédé impôts
cc la richesse que l'on crée c'est un
cercle vertueux mais c'est vers ça que
l'on doit aller on va passer à la
dernière question je relance la route je
vous laisse la réplique on le fêter
vous aviez deux fois sharp assure le
haut que d'un certain au cas où on tombe
sur les mots j du drapeau français c'est
une question sur laquelle tombent tous
les candidats en fin d'interview vous
allez en fait devoir reprendre une
formule la formule de françois hollande
face à nicolas sarkozy en 2012 le fameux
mois président alors pour vous aider là
dessus évidemment le reprendre à votre
compte il va y avoir des débuts de
phrases qui vont s'afficher à l'écran je
voulais c'est lire le début de phrase
est complétée je continue comme vous
souhaitez en une phrase à surfer
exactement et je voulais ce camp seck la
première qui s'affiche à l'écran
- président les jeunes je souhaite
pouvoir leur garantir l'égalité des
droits quelle que soit leur couleur leur
origine leur religion leur handicap
l'égalité pour la jeunesse c'est ma
priorité
noah président mon ennemi sera toujours
la finance mais à la différence de
hollande qui l'a dit la finance n'est
pas invisible elle a des noms à la d
adresse et moi je les connais et ils
participeront à la reconstruction de la
france
moi président ma première mesure sera de
tout de suite augmenter les salaires
augmenter les retraites pour pouvoir
redonner du pouvoir d'achat à tous ceux
et toutes celles qui travaillent et à
ceux qui ont passé une vie au travail
pour pouvoir vivre dignement de son
travail
moi présidents les plus riches
participeront tout simplement à la
reconstruction de la france et à ar à
restaurer un véritable budget au service
de la nation au service de l'emploi au
service du climat tout le monde doit
participer et avec moi présidents les
plus riches participeront et le dernier
mois président la france sera la france
des jours heureux celle qui restera une
république sincère une république au
service du peuple de l'égalité des
droits de tous une république laïque
universaliste féministe écologiste merci
fabien roussel d'avoir accepté de 0,2
nouvelle fois tout toutes ces questions
là je précise d'ailleurs pour tous ceux
qui nous regardent que cette vidéo comme
pour tous les autres candidats à la
présidentielle qui gênent ti ci
s'accompagne d'une vidéo de décryptage
de votre programme on présente dix
mesures majeures porter dans votre
programme qui est donc ou qui sera
disponible dans les prochains jours
directement sur cette chaîne youtube
d'ailleurs pour ce que tu nous regardes
pour découvrir du coup toutes les autres
interview déjà publiée mais aussi les
décryptages des programmes vous pouvez
vous abonner directement ici et vous
pouvez aussi découvrir sur instagram
d'autres contenus exclusifs de
comparaison notamment des programmes des
candidats encore merci fabien roussel
pour mercy présence aujourd'hui et de
l'autre côté on se dit ah très vite